I'd like Tyrion to be there I think he's
my favorite character he's very funny as
well
Tyrion or Daenerys really I'd say I
would love it if it was area or even
brand it would be Daenerys Targaryen
Lisa I think she will as well
if I could I'd go down to lay bricks and
put money on it
Ron would be a really cool Kim so I'm
solving the Robert Ratheon mold I think
maybe he might mold into that sort King
baby fun with me I think ultimately the
Starks should triumph but that remains
to be seen if it's someone who you think
will get to the Iron Throne probably
won't be so yeah I don't know someone
who deserves it I think Breanna's she is
one of the good guys she's not shy swing
a sword
so if need be then to get the job done
me I should because my client is the
best and I see our hero so yeah I is
really cool chick I need to be a pretty
good brawler REO would be quite a good
hand but to the right King
how star going away I have to say
start all the way only say Gendry I mean
Gendry is like he has a claim for one -
I think you'd be a good king I think I
think he'd look after his people what
kind of King do you think he would make
I think it'd be a real champion of the
underdog and I think it'd be I think
it'd be a really fair and just king from
the point of view of my character it has
to be Daenerys because that's what I've
know ways and certainly it would seem at
this stage that is shaping that way
maybe John I don't want Daenerys to
because he's got the dragons she's like
got an advantage it would be so
predictable if she ended up on the
throne Jon Snow
you know there's a different story there
Jon Snow is not who he appears to be and
I think we learned something interesting
about Jon Snow well if you're a centavos
it's a no-brainer isn't it we got to get
Stannis on he's the right man for the
job I'm gonna have to say Janeiro's yeah
yeah I would like to see Daenerys on the
Iron Throne with the Dragons on ruling
the roost
yeah she's got dragons and that throne
enough please you can't have all
Daenerys an alternative choice to be
like jaqen H'ghar something really weird
I think I'd like to stage a can and come
back and be the last one on the Iron
Throne
Betsy I want to say stark but then
things do change and you do find
yourself being more involved in another
character storyline or you think oh I
liked you
you're a not a word I can say here
that's better
what would King Hodor
well it would kill anyone who's not dead
taking the chat rule with a fair harms
do you think it'd take us Queenie me do
I think you could probably ask our sure
to come back I think I think cooler
would have a better I crashed on Archer
that she's in a junk as well so I think
she'd probably come back if I could have
my own king or queen of Westeros who
would it be the hot tree you know you
know the tree the the the I go with the
tree Daenerys is very strong and and a
powerful woman who end up here with a
conscience who would make a great Queen
but she has that sort of petulant side
as well it's as good which is a bit hard
to handle
I think it's not going to be anyone
obvious I don't think it's gonna be
Danny I don't think it's gonna be John I
don't think it's going to be anyone that
we think I think it will be a really it
might be a character we haven't seen yet
it also for my money it could be Lord
Varys because I think he probably knows
more about what's going on than anyone
else you know the kind of the White
Walkers obviously the kind of that slim
racy kind of guy I have this thing of a
head where I kind of see this guy sort
of lounging with one leg over the arm of
the chair and he's just sitting there
with a married eating grin well I'd be
sitting on the throne of course I think
tyrion has the best quote in it if you
think this is going to have a have a
happy ending you haven't been paying
attention
I wouldn't like see any of them on it
because they're all awful
you